people's trailer commentaries for it
1990 version yeah talk about and was it
far
quite quite on the set you guys I'm
trying to intro alright sorry the hats
are talking so this is a show we're
talking about the thought process behind
this trailer and if you stick around and
get you to some deleted scenes and
comments from viewers like you
now speak long Joe I like the 1990
that's a good year five year from
anything the main insight that we had in
the room that I think we started off
from is just don't do this for TV you
know you don't have the money you don't
have the time you don't have the
resources you can't really scare people
it's 9:00 p.m. it's ABC just don't do it
so a thousand-page book you just don't
need this is not the one to adapt for
teller but some carries great though
that's the things like he's the one
thing that people remembered why I think
why I like people remember it being
better than it is because it is it's a
bit of a slog yeah Jim Curry's had a
whole career out of being like the best
part of terrible movies I almost have to
another 100gb
ami ridiculous Hungarian accent maybe
all floats the best part Congo was
diamonds that shoot lasers and the line
these monkeys are smart too smart
[Laughter]
also I would say Ernie Hudson item
carrier vying for the best thing in
condo award I almost have to recuse
myself from all it related content
because I am on the record and famously
known as someone who does not find
clowns frightening in the least
I find them sad my heart breaks for a
clown it's trying to be scary I just
call a clown you're out of work trying
to drum up some scares it's just like to
capturing the Friedman's yes yeah clowns
aren't scary to me
so Tim Curry's take on this also was
kind of like like a Bronx blue-collar
out-of-work clown who's just relied on
popping up in shower drains somewhere
but I know if it hit you in 1990 this
would probably freak you out but I mean
I think this to me feels like the start
of the clowns are terrifying thing like
that was an 80s trope so I feel like he
was big adventure was the start of this
kind of like riding the hey we've just
discovered that clowns can be scary wave
you know I found that when I was three
and I find clowns extraordinarily
disconcerting I'm wondering if it's
because it's like the man but when you
get close you see like the humanity
underneath but it's like covered in this
this unreal
those aren't real people who were sort
of coming of age in the 80s looked back
at their Halloween costumes as children
from the 50s and 60s when their parents
dressed them as clowns and they looked
horrifying and that's what really like
drummed it up they're like my god what
happened cuz I do feel like it's a
generational like kids in the 50s
weren't like scared of clowns I know
they're rabble I think they're right
they like the circus comes to town it's
exciting it was probably the the
Pagliacci joke where things regardless
we've done the new it now we're doing
the old it nineties it nineties it
there's some boring background
information we can talk about because we
had written this for awhile and then
kind of put it in a drawer and then
write it back out
mm-hmm and that's that important except
that the first draft it's it's a
an example of how far Joe has come as a
writer because he's not good we dusted
off the first draft and then you're like
come on and then the second draft yeah
current Joe yeah yeah chefs fingers two
years ago Joe real piece of [ __ ] hire
that guy yeah Spencer Jay Gilbert the
guy that can find the corn trailer for
it 1990 and don't mind coming for the TV
Oh November eighteenth nineteen
ninety-two new ABC at a p.m. Eastern for
America's Funniest Videos with Bob Saget
then at 8:30 it's America's Funniest
people with Dave Coulier then at nine
gather the kids for part one of the
miniseries about the cloud that will
each return who's the boss
followed by head of the class and at
9:00 it's part two of the miniseries
above the clown that will eat your
children
it pause so we did we did do the
research and that was actually the
lineup it was America's Funniest Home
Videos and America's Funniest people
before part one yeah what was america's
funniest people america's I'm familiar
with surprised said what could get
America's Funniest people it was part of
the America's plenty of verse ya
companion to America's Funniest Home
Videos and they were on full house you
got to honey so video this was first yes
and then that had like two very
successful seasons there was YouTube and
they were like oh we got it hiss let's
get more videos and another full house
cast member
right so the hook was with America's
Funniest people that it wasn't like
accidental it wasn't like oh he fell
down a hill it was like people trying to
be wacky Goofy's are you yeah it's
basically programming to like the big
hook around it was they would go to like
malls and stuff and do appearances as
you know um did yeah I'm funny like I'm
double-jointed or I could do this funny
thing with my face like it really was a
lot of that but the moment there was any
kind of story arc then it got shunted
back to Funniest Videos
oh yeah I really popped on funniest
people yeah yeah and the Dave Coulier
also had a recurring character named the
Jackalope rabid or something but it had
antlers right taped on to it zoo
illogical Garrick it was like a
first-person like the camera was mounted
on its head and it's like voice based
comic in the 90s it was like the dream
vehicle for Jeff anytime the Jackalope
came on the bone I have to pick with
America's Funniest Videos slash Got
Talent is that they you know people go
oh well YouTube's ruined America's
Funniest Home Videos but America's
Funniest Home Videos ruined the sports
blooper videotape genre oh yeah videos
before the networks were like let's take
their money thank yous to order those
used to order away from those things man
someone made those I loved a good
bloopers VHS
three outfielders running into each
other and it sounded big you wouldn't
have Bob Saget doing hilarious voices
yeah yeah new episodes of who's the boss
and head of the class led into head of
the class baby nights later well that is
an accurate reflection of the ABC
primetime line thank God your apartment
is full of TV Guide
so shut Stan's wife like believe it we
use she's watching perfect strangers
which is also part of ABC's lineup at
this time healthy joke later right let's
see what are you Disney corporate
synergy Kingdom for ABC move over Jared
Leto because it's time to bow down to
the real king of murder clouds Tim Curry
a serial killing demon clown from the
Bronx who due to network censorship
guidelines expresses his evil through
bad teeth and mild YouTube pranks
[Music]
delivery their voice just like like a
like a young person who's been bullied
for hours it's so melodramatic
yeah but I also like this to me was like
I think we did a really good job or we
did the best job we could but like
that's the hardest thing to capture
about this movie is that Pennywise is
like not doing anything scary he's
usually like goofing or all it's the
implication right it's like I know that
there's a clown's not there so the fact
that the clown is appearing before my
eyes is scary yeah nothing de facto he's
doing is scary at all which is a big
stumbling block it's like something they
say just has to be friends yeah like it
really does feel a lot of the time you
could play the scenes like without the
context of this is a horror movie and it
does feel like he's just right
change the soundtrack and it's Joe's
favorite show Impractical Jokers you
want to be friends one of the
Impractical Jokers Joe you've stopped
second favorite would definitely do the
moving drains in the shower thing like
yeah then one of them in the locker room
and moving that's giving Impractical
Jokers far too much credit the
Impractical Jokers shower drain gag
would be there would be some people
taking a shower and they'd be like and
we just send Joey and II wanted to tell
people that are one of the showers of
spraying peepee and then he walks into
the people taking a shower and he's like
one of the showers the spraying Fifi and
then it cuts back to the other
Impractical Jokers going good how do
they come up with new material I know
right that's not at all practical he's
telling people that the showers are
gonna spray Pia yeah three hours I cut
away to Tim Curry like he's amazing in
this he's having fun
daiquiris enjoying himself he seems like
he gets what the movie is and should be
where does everybody else is really
going for it hello Joey
yeah like he gets that it's like a
schlocky and be hard okay let's keep
going picture but even more horrifying
is this vampire clown it's true form of
blood lab
a spooky flood man who says Stephen King
doesn't know how to write an ending
return to the 90s version of what the
movies 80s were the seventies a time
when cops were Irish the bullies I guess
in in the newer it to are so much more
terrifying to me than the clown yes
they're like a real tangible threat yeah
everyone's got a knife I guess back then
you just always had a Whitwell knife or
a stabbing knife and they constantly are
threatening children with murder yes the
bullies are outright homicidal right
from the start
in this one now full disclosure I often
don't remember the book because I get to
a point with a lot of Stephen King books
where I'm just like oh what what are you
doing and like I'm like a because it's
like it's like a child trying to explain
YouTube to its grandpa and I'm grandpa
and I'm like no no more Stephen King
trying to explain his startup ideas on a
fourth bag of blow but I think that's
the point like I think he's just like a
psychic vampire II thing so he uses the
bullies to scare they're in the book
yeah spider they can kill you kill the
kids because the power of friendship
yeah a little bit more of it in the
movie or at least the first movie I
haven't seen the second one where it's
like the whole town of Derry is infected
by this evil presence and there's one
scene where Bev remembers like that guy
didn't help me out it's like everybody's
wrong with everybody
yeah like that's the ideas like the
bullies are more evil everybody's more
sisters everybody's eating off of it
everybody's looking the other way
ignoring evil in front of them because
that's just life and dairy and I know
that would be a very interesting thing
for them to have children to explore
they may or may not choose to go into
maybe instead every three hours see a
Cynthia bike riding sea
we could've maybe yeah the sequel by the
way it's chapter 2 as long as this
entire literally will say danjel anyone
who's seen it but reviews are mixed
let's see yeah I keep going and the fat
kids we're skinny and meet the losers
Club no really
if you're under there's all these people
my first time in your life John Ritter
made great strides modeling the dead
from Sister Sister and these guys will
talk about sex and put a pin on these
guys these particularly the gun battle
will be coming back to it yeah our old
basa we have a great silent hold
majority us I thought we were talking to
children but it turns out there's a lot
it's all my parents Church friends yeah
people every week they're like do para
max of you a story it's a fine example
the parish the st. Thomas and Louisville
is really riled up right now it sucked
up it must have sucked to be an old nerd
when like you got this passionate about
a crappy little house woman who gives it
the counterparts guy from Seaquest I
thought that was a yeah everyone else
come on Ted Danson wasn't available
couldn't book a young NVH Pinchot Bakula
al
I can shot him but no sir I'm not at all
I can't remember much of anything and
when I try it kind of clouds over where
the less interesting adult version of
the losers grow up that spends most of
the time wishing they weren't there
eating Chinese food staring off into
space [ __ ] around on a bike and
finally facing off against a dumb spider
good luck Bill Hader so revisit a noble
effort that was doomed from the start
with the super low budget the
constraints of TV sensors and aspect
ratios and three hours to tell a
thousand-page story just stop before you
get started next time okay if you can't
afford the cosmic turtle weird games
cause that's in case you didn't see it
spoiler alert there was Alan oh one of
the more hidden talents hop right side
of your screen you will Amy Allan
zooming bullet go back yep I think the
right you can barely see Alan - letting
go you can barely see them against the
starfield and it's like a magic eye or a
right quadrant of the focus your eyes
Spencer I don't know just no you idiot -
scooter this is for the audience at home
okay they can't see this monitor great
perfect thank you Dad thank you Dad
[Applause]
thanks dad okay so is that easy enough
here is a sailboat stupid-head we were
able to get it after five minutes of
staring and Dan pointing at it no
problem and that is michurin michurin
that's her natural natural chand who's
back
it's a whole thing which is also like a
stupid riddle and it's also Discworld
which is great and it's also Paul
Bettany's name and Master and Commander
even metrid I never knew that first oh
yeah they're also Turtles play a large
isn't that what he wanted to go see -
yeah good luck well you want to go to
Gough
yeah so we're Stephen King confirmed
yeah awesome parent hurdle or even a
decent cave spider don't adapt it or the
Dark Tower or the stand or L'Engle ears
or really anything Stephen King Dairy
Queen Levana board member flashback
phase I think these are the audition you
didn't Eve they didn't even read yeah
just show us your best remembering
something face the osmotics are coming
much no joke here just a moment to
appreciate how good it whenever you're
jonathan brandis when he sidekick spat
kill it it's okay the kids again in the
bus car yes winner of the very
prestigious architect a worthless
architecting
when I drink I always bring champagne
showgirls back tonight hey coming soon
see we found a straight way to whatever
this movie is as of this writing rich is
still knocked my head apart he's got a
part in a movie chicken right I don't I
can't even tell what it is it looks like
I've got like a inner tube or something
my working theory is that this is a
silent film like like a comedic version
of the artist or something like that
where they're doing like a remake of a
Marx Brothers or an even earlier thing
we're like it doesn't matter what
they're saying they're gonna cut to a
black and white scream is my duck I
don't even think they've got that box no
love fake snow unless they're filming
their torsos also and then from the
Miami Vice set there's a palm tree not
in front of the know how to make
something so you have to try to make
something this incoherent Wow like it
would have been much easier just having
at a table or something it's so weird
that I do wonder if there was like an
alt thing where the other guy turns
around and he has a red nose and you do
the like this is all a fantasy
starring like terrible Lewis and Clark
comedy I would challenge our viewers who
instead of just complaining about we'll
get to it put it back up JT is treat
this like a New York or caption contest
two people two adult men jesting with
tennis rackets with fake snow being
poured on them you write that caption
and you make it make sense that's art
that's how I did you bleed it out next
week making a line from Alf yes
product cats all right never mind
contest keep going
[Music]
dairy stories to tell in the dark
I don't see what the big deal is this
happens almost every time I get my Panda
Express on yeah young chicken with bugs
it's pretty good you guys were with a
Panda Express
I feel like PF Changs is my go-to I'm
gonna make a joke about bad Chinese food
yeah I agree
like I I would have thought peanut
Jencks Saint Express has a delightful
new item that's like like a hot Szechuan
they're getting on the hot chicken phase
one strips yeah mm-hmm good I love it
I I loved it I the taste was incredible
yeah but the ended the burn Mel's that
came out like my insides my god my mouth
afterwards were unlike anything I've
ever friends together
it was delicious no I agree I'll tell
you after I ate that it did not float to
watch this down Brian
totally I need some milk from the store
what's impressive is not just that you
could do the voice well but that you're
capable of like Alf reference number
four yeah like eight times you get home
from work to know Mac and I'm Gordon
it'll name is Gordon Shumway you've also
managed to give us a certain team now as
you wait for chapter two to take you
back to clown town you can't help but
wonder what if it was low-budget
made-for-tv and bad why would you even
wonder that we rose it
the low-budget made-for-tv bad one that
was because that was an original intro
yeah
but then just the baby it was so fun
that originally came after the title of
the great we agreed like I think we
should just there you go
joke explained let's keep going all
right Rocky Horror Picture Show I care
Spencer good
baman baman and harriet man justice for
bail wait is that the TRO - guy the it
crowd the day the clown died in jail
luis rahman yes coming soon good well
yeah would have gone over with our fans
60 year old geriatric fans
the bellhop fans the day the clown died
gonna come out soon it was like 2023
some pervy so that he had that it after
certain time after he dies i think he
could or yeah there's yes i think we
will see it will do the honest trailer
for that yeah and the feel feel like we
should you're miss an opportunity to say
it stinks I'm legitimately worried that
the Night Court references rule so we
should address the middle-aged elephant
the room which is that the boomers my
room the boom in the room that the
entire comment section is about how that
guy played john-boy Walton Richard
Richard Thomas who plays the older build
n bro in the film areas in the middle we
Jon Blunk two men with this guy on
classic CBS drama series The Waltons
which ran for nine years starting in
1972 went off the air in 1970 when I
looked it said he played him from 1971
to 1971 john-boy disappears for the last
few years he stopped playing john-boy
yes in like 79 four decades I was one
year old Alana was one I was negative
five I don't understand just lurking
like this is a huge phantom it look
we're not here to criticize anybody's
fandom we are just doing this out of a
complete ignorance that there was this
you in fact to make sure you check out
the Waltons fandom community which I'm
sure is alive and thriving on family
that Richard Thomas was john-boy Walton
I had no clue
I knew that look like come on it's such
an old reference it didn't even occur to
me that we should make an honest trailer
joke about it I'm the Godzilla thing I
saw coming because I know that there's a
lot of work I never in my wildest dream
it's believed that we would be set upon
by a rabid pack of Brendan Alan see you
guys seriously gloss over the fact
john-boy Walton was in the sex audio
they said nothing by Richard Thomas
haven't played john-boy I see screen
duckies employees don't watch a good
prime top-tier TV shows like The Waltons
it's it's not it's not that people are
like gotcha cause people like to do that
with these videos it's like we miss
stuff well you've missed this or you
didn't mention this random thing that is
what I think about why did you think
it's still an anger it's like I'm
waiting waiting for their opportunity
yeah like oh and it's like every other
comment they're gonna do the the 1998
finally we'll get some john-boy Walton
jokes like we've been all waiting for
all this time I will never worry about
another one of our references being
someone donated $10,000 generously for
us to do all of Doctor Who if you venmo
me personally $5,000 okay I will do a
bootleg unofficial doesn't include our
editing team or our voiceover or the
actually talented writers and I will
write and make the Waltons on a screen
so because for like 25 seasons were like
24 watch it with my parents they had to
sit through the Waltons with my parents
I'm not making fun of people that like
the Waltons it's just that in such great
numbers they they came like the shaming
us yeah for not making a 40 year old
television reference
yeah well I'm trying depression-era
eighties drama you bastards
like Greg Brady Maisy or even like oh if
we'd said Barry Williams it was Greg
Brady but we definitely have had classic
TV stars on and not mention the classic
TV shows I'm about john-boy like lose
their mind anything like Richard Thomas
would be like hey he's still working
he's on the Americans like right okay
Richard Thomas efforts I thought yeah
maybe we would make because we mentioned
Night Court and now they were angry that
we did not and I wish I wish everyone
else could see like the the the a of
this BNC story where we were all sitting
around like all of these jokes are so
all like every time we weird try link
and now no one's gonna give it maybe
these references
sweet sweet John Ritter I don't know I
hope so yeah same but we're and like
Jonathan Brandis we were like hey like
does anyone remember Seaquest you're
like poring over all the ropes in the
starring this time because we were like
people aren't gonna get references to
all the movies and shows these guys were
in so we just have to adjust our
expectations of our audience who I
always assume we're stupid babies but it
turns out that they're actually angry
old people except for you you know I had
this shocked me this really I thought I
was sure that it was going to be because
it's usually something I was sure that
it was gonna be people that thought and
we actually went back and we recorded
that we hadn't given Tim Curry enough
credit for how great he is in the movie
and we went back we beef that up but I
still thought if you who asked me I
would've said people are gonna be upset
I usually give Tim Curry no don't
Jenn Zebes stuff like oh you didn't say
Kim Possible was the greatest animated
series of all time I did not see the
other half I did Datsuns know I guess
they just don't they don't have stuff to
be angry with us about usually yeah like
we don't we don't get the old people
upset with there you go so next week
we're going after rebel scooters Grand
Funk Railroad you have to be careful
because like if you keep coming at us
like this we will not come home over the
holidays to program your VCR we won't do
it
we're done yeah player yourself motion
smoothing is just gonna stay on john-boy
is gonna look like he's on a weird old
soap opera the other half of the
comments section is the our perennial
favorite an hour apart from cinemasins
coincident it's not a coincidence yeah
it's like we upload the same day like
that your upload on Tuesdays and we do -
we do - and couple hours before yeah and
look at the movie calendars yeah like
when the movie either it's when the new
movies come out on home video or digital
or it's like tie in - yeah okay and
that's not to say that we don't take fan
requests into account we see what you
guys doing but then we look at the
calendar and look for a place where it
works most sense and I assume that the
people at Sandra Zins do the same thing
and then once we make that decision we
look to the rest of the room at the
YouTube Illuminati Dabba go yep movies
gets to drink the blood first yeah and
then we all plan our video calendar yeah
all hail the algorithm all right finally
detai writes Tim Curry will always be my
favorite penny wise what is yours slash
what distinguishes the two from each
other Tim Curry versus there's only one
other choice really or the band or I'm
gonna go with the band seminal because
I'm neither cloud save throw him so if I
could get Tim Curry to give me a number
one that's completely fair I think
that's very fair
I think skarsgård he brings a lot more
like a natural alienness to it like Tim
Curry is basically playing a clown like
a man who's a clown and he's just like
an evil sadistic clown until you find
out he's like an underground crab right
spider monster skarsgård the whole time
he's like doing weird stuff with his
voice and with his face and he's trying
to seem like not human I find that more
outright frightening and sinister and
unsettling
stay for me I I think I'm the only
person that didn't really love the new
it a whole lot and I thought that really
there's only one scene or skarsgård got
to perform to me that wasn't just
jump-scare I'm a leper and that was when
uh the kid falls in the house and he
like breaks his arm and he's on the
ground and he's like marching towards
him and that was like one of the one
scenes rather not just like let's just
pile a bunch of effects on Pennywise and
he actually gets to perform for an
extended period of time and like just be
scary just being skarsgård so I don't
know I'm gonna go I'm gonna go curry but
also just because he's great and loaded
weapon one fair enough
hey that's kinda like James Bond for me
it's like I love Sean Connery how he
played James Bond I equally also for
different love the early Daniel Craig
movies and now he played it's it's like
there was a anyways yeah I love those
scars but yeah I never get the complaint
that the new it is like I'll jump scary
cuz it's not like I'm so sensitive jump
scares in there
compared to other horror movies they're
very relatively few job like there's a
lot of people I think that look at the
nuit movies and are just like it's too
many jump scares I'm like it but it
doesn't really have that many jump
scares I that's what I like about it is
it's legitimately creepy and scary it
doesn't rely on that yeah III they both
are great it's hard for me so like this
one's better than the other because I
love how both of them play the character
and it's not like one's derivative of
another one as far as like yeah I think
that's what I really appreciate it's
like they've totally go different ways
with it yeah yeah well there you go I
never looked at Bill scars Garner's like
oh he's just doing Tim Curry you know
weird his own even guys watch Castle
Rock the Hulu knows anything serious it
was pretty good but he's also in it and
playing another like he looks human but
he's also like a creepy Stephen King
monster and he's just he's really good
at it he's just very good it's just got
this like something's off about this guy
but I can't put my finger on it
vibe too but I think we can all agree
that the scary is
clown is the one in the painting that my
grandma got me that my mom made me keep
on my wall of every Christmas when they
come to visit
oh yeah no doubt you realize a little
Bart with the clown band was not happy
can't sleep finally take it down before
I went to bed at night my mom would come
in see that get very upset put it back
I'd wake up and it was back in that was
how it explains so much quarter piece
all right well thank you all for
watching the honest row commentary for
it come back next week when we'll be
taking you all over the world right and
am I getting am I not getting my make my
weeks mixed up no you're right yeah I
can show you guys some some fantastic
sights it'll be magical well good night
Spencer good night very good we're gonna
do the pit remember like good night
Spencer good night Dan Oh from the
Waltons Oh we'll be retired to the
dustbin of history if anything Sammy
based on the fandom sorry
[Laughter]
[Music]
you